quand les médecins ne savent plus
comment soigner leur patients face à une
pénurie de médicaments qui s'aggravent
faire une ordonnance devient un
casse-tête écoutez à ce propos ce
médecin tour en jeu
dans une période où vous êtes doublés
qui surinfectent qu'il y a des
pneumopathies des infections pulmonaires
dans l'eau ne pas pouvoir utiliser les
antibiotiques communément
usés en première nécessité
là ça devient ça devient compliqué voilà
pour ce témoignage des médecins obligés
de s'adapter parce que les pharmacies
peinent à sa provisionner alors comment
tentait de panier ces ruptures de
médicaments voient ça avec notre invité
ce soir on sort Olivier Julien
Lafferrière bonsoir cette pharmacien
jouer les tours et vice-président du
syndicat fsps en Indre-et-Loire quels
sont les médicaments qui sont en rupture
de stock aujourd'hui alors des
médicaments rupture il y en a
régulièrement il y en a déjà beaucoup
trop mais en ce moment il y a une
pénurie effectivement plutôt dramatique
sur des antibiotiques exactement
l'amoxicilline pédiatrique donc pour les
tout-petits et puis alors le paracétamol
des médicaments pour l'asthme des
traitements de fond surtout et puis les
sur antitussif alors là peut-être un peu
moins grave des expectorants des choses
comme ça voilà et la cortisone notamment
là la cortisone manque aussi sous
certaines formes on est obligé de faire
des équivalences de dosage pour avoir le
traitement nécessaire c'est pas toujours
facile notamment pour les petits cette
situation est-elle inédite à ce point-là
oui elle est vraiment inédite oui on a
connu des périodes avec des des ruptures
qui duraient un certain temps puis qui
revenait dans la dans la normale là
c'est vrai que ça menace en plus de
durée parce que là c'est un phénomène
qui est mondial international niveau
européen on n'a pas encore c'est un
projet d'avoir des mutualisations des
stocks de façon à pouvoir s'échanger
tout ça pour pouvoir voilà faire face
mais oui ça ça va être compliqué c'est
complètement inédit oui avec une
spécificité française
a organisé un petit peu oui parce qu'en
fait bon c'est vrai que cette grande
pandémie qu'on a eu évidemment rien
arrangé dans deux sens d'abord parce
qu'elle est là et qu'elle a pu
déclencher des surinfections comme le
disait le dans votre reportage et puis
aussi parce que
nous allons avoir
je sais plus ce que je voulais dire moi
là voilà ça c'est une situation
extrêmement critique qui touche
notamment la France comment vous faites
face à une situation ce que vous
fabriquez par exemple des médicaments
alors personnellement les fabrique pas
on donne des des solutions en appui avec
la Société française de pédiatrie pour
les produits justement pour les enfants
on utilise des médicaments adultes qu'on
met en solution donne des pipettes on
explique aux gens on perd beaucoup
beaucoup de temps comme les médecins à
essayer de voilà de trouver des
médicaments d'expliquer les traitements
de façon c'est pas simple ouais ouais
voilà tout à fait alors tout ce qui est
rare et cher ce que les prix augmentent
alors le prix du médicament ne fait que
baisser c'est justement ce que je
voulais dire c'est là le problème ça
fait 20 ans que le l'État français
organise finalement petit à petit ce
risque pénurie et là avec cette pandémie
ça la déclenché c'est-à-dire qu'on se
retrouve aussi avec des laboratoires qui
vont livrer en priorité des endroits où
ça s'est rémunérateur c'est logique
c'est l'Armée du Salut c'est nos
salaires aussi dans dans nos emplois
dans certaines entreprises françaises ça
ne filtrage voilà il faut bien qu'ils
puissent produire payer ses employés
donc voilà on a cherché à diminuer
diminuer diminuer le coup l'Allemagne
est dans exactement dans le même dans le
même cas que nous est en train de
s'organiser une grosse réforme chez eux
pour justement essayer de faire
regrimper notamment avoir une comment
dire faire venir des médicaments de
l'étranger notamment la Chine l'Inde
Israël et puis d'un pays européen de
façon à avoir au moins à hauteur de 20
ou 30% un approvisionnement qui
permettrait de de pouvoir faire face
d'assurer l'approvisionnement quel
conseil vous donneriez aux personnes qui
nous regardent qui voilà voudrait
s'approvisionner en alors en paracétamol
il y en a mais en tout cas dans d'autres
médicaments
aux soignants et notamment en pharmacien
qui trouvent des solutions dès qu'ils le
peuvent et puis nous sommes aussi
mutualisés c'est-à-dire qu'on est
capable de savoir à quel endroit un
pharmacien a pu avoir quelques boîtes
parce qu'en fait la répartition
pharmaceutique c'est elle qui est
approvisionnée maintenant par les
laboratoires on peut plus acheter en
direct et donc de cette façon là ils
vont mettre sur le sur tout le sur tout
le territoire des boîtes à disposition
de tous les pharmaciens et donc on peut
toujours savoir à quel endroit une
pharmacie à quelque chose et donc on
envoie mais le problème c'est
qu'effectivement quand une maman s'en va
voilà qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire ah bah
ça va être des hospitalisations donc
encombrement des urgences enfin on
continue sur le schéma habituel qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas bon merci
beaucoup Olivier Julien Laferrière
pharmacien jouer les tours d'être venu
ce soir sur notre plateau